le général Augusto pinoché est arrivé
aujourd'hui dans la capitale du Chili
Santiago le vieux dictateur que l'on
disait incapable de marcher de répondre
à des questions mentalement affaiblies a
semblé pourtant très en forme dans son
pays bon pied bon œil le général 84 ans
une simple canne à la main a reconnu son
entourage qu'il attendait avec
impatience après 17 mois de séjour forcé
en Grande-Bretagne c'est officiellement
pour des raisons de santé que les
autorités britanniques ont estimé qu'il
ne pouvaiit subir un procès sur place le
reportage de nos envoyers spéciaux
Dominique derda et Édouard
Perin ils l'auront attendu longtemps le
général Pinochet 17 mois durant lesquels
il fut assigné à résidence en Angleterre
et quelques heures encore ce matin sur
la piste de l'aéroport de Santiago mais
enfin il est
arrivé surprise de toute évidence le
vieillard libéré pour raison humanitaire
n'a pas trop souffert ni de l'exil ni du
voyage ce doit re l'air du pays qui lui
donne la force de se lever de son
fauteuil
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
roulant
notre institution continuera à donner
son appui permanent et solidaire au
général Augusto
pinoch il ne se fais gu d'illusion ces
manifestants d'organisation de défense
des droits de l'homme venu crier leur
rage devant le quartier général de
l'armée il voulait tester la
détermination des soldats la réponse n'a
pas
tardé
[Applaudissements]
le Pinochet qu'on a découvert ce matin
sa descente d'avion était en bien
meilleure forme que ce qu'on a voulu
nous faire croire à tel point que je me
demande s'il ne s'agit pas d'une farce
ou d'un arrangement politique parce que
vraiment il n'avait pas l'air si malade
que
cela lorsque son hélicoptère se pose sur
le toit de l'hôpital ils sont des
milliers les partisans d'Augusto pinoch
mass autour du bâtiment dans les rues de
l'un des quartiers aisés de la capitale
longtemps ils ont cru que jamais on leur
rendrait leur idole ce soir non
seulement Pinochet dormira au milieu des
siens mais déjà ont dit qu'il pourrait
bientôt pourquoi pas reprendre son siège
au
Sénat Dominique bonsoir vous êtes en
direct de Santiago alors la surprise
c'est que Pinochet apparî franchement
très en forme ce n'est plus un retour
c'est une résurrection
oui Françoise on pourrait même dire une
guérison miraculeuse et à tel point
qu'on pourrait même se demander
effectivement si Pinochet n'a pas fait
un détour par lourde avant de prendre la
destination de Santiago où il est arrivé
ce matin vous savez Lucia sa fille aînée
déclarait tout à l'heure à la presse en
à l'arrivée peu après l'arrivée de son
père que que pardon qu'Augusto pinoché
était un homme brisé quand il est monté
à bord de l'appareil en Angleterre et au
au fil du temps plus il se rapprochait
du Chili de sa ternatal mieux il se
sentait alors évidemment on est en droit
de se poser quelques questions sur la
validité de de ses premières impressions
et puis surtout des expertises des
médecins britanniques qui l'ont déclaré
absolument inapte à subir un procès cela
dit au Chili ça ne changera rien quel
que soit son état de santé le juge
guusman qui instruit une soixantaine de
plaintes contre contre Augusto Pinochet
contre l'ancien dictateur a bien
l'intention d'aller au bout de cette
instruction et il demandera très
certainement la levée de l'immunité
parlementaire de du sénateur avis merci
beaucoup Dominique